what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python and panitch tutorial
video in this video we're going to
talking about how we can actually graph
with pandas so pain is actually really
good at intuitively plotting your data
so if you're familiar with doing
matplotlib and all of that with some of
my other videos sometimes especially
when you involve dates they can get kind
of difficult to plot but with pandas
it's actually quite simple so anyway
with that let's go ahead and we don't
really need this stuff anymore but we'll
need it a little bit so obviously value
that there but anyway to plot we're
gonna go ahead and import mat plot lived
up pie plot as PLT for folks who are
following along with ipython notebook
you actually don't need to import this
we just have to import it here so we can
do plot dot show otherwise the plot
never shows up but pandas actually does
this entirely pandas has matplotlib
built in to it so when you tell Pena's
to plot
it'll plot and if you were in ipython
notebook it would show it to you but if
you're not you have to call plot does
show so anyway if you're on ipython
notebook you don't have to do this i
it's funny a lot of people use pandas
with ipython notebook because to them it
helps them develop faster and also test
things faster and save settings and all
this I sort of understand that but at
the same time I develop much slower with
ipython notebook simply because every
input produces output and this is very
annoying but anyway just as a note if
you're on ipython notebook you won't
need to do that moving on let's give all
these prints here that we can leave
everything else though I mean we can
leave the definition of 100 moving
average and all of that and to plot it's
actually super simple you can do
something as easy as and in fact
actually I changed my mind let well I
will leave all there we can do it's as
simple as this gift uh plot so if you
had a data frame
and it only had data in there that you
really wanted to plot all in the same
chart it's as simple as doing DF dot
plot and then we could do PLT show might
take a second but probably not too long
I think it's that much data right and
here is our plot now there's a couple of
problems doing it this way is one we see
it clearly this purple line what is that
well that's volume because that's our
largest value so we plot it everything
on the same chart and so the biggest
thing is volume as you can see with our
exponent here what all the data is
actually plotted here we could probably
find it if we zoomed in a lot it's
looking better looking better oh look at
us anyway so you can't just plot it so
simple to plot look really quick but
another thing that you can do is instead
of saying say DF not plot the other
thing okay a couple things one you can
plot
doing like say for example you want to
do PLT quixote dot plot and then you can
plot data in here so you could say DF
100ma and that should actually work just
fine let's try it real quick
right and so it plots the 100 but you'll
notice down here it doesn't have a date
there and so that's kind of a bummer and
so you can plot but this is using the
typical matplotlib right to plot where
instead we can use pandas to plot and
pandas is smart it's intuitive so what
we can do instead is we can do something
like this D F and then we could say just
let's say we just want to do clothes do
you have to close dot plot empty parms
save and run that and now look at us we
have dates at the bottom and again if
you have not followed my other tutorials
or if you have you know that's pretty
nice that you didn't have to do any date
formatting it just does it for you so we
can zoom into spots and it kind of gives
us the actual day and all that now it
doesn't get any higher granularity just
simply because our data isn't it's just
the highest it gets us by one day so we
have our day data so that's how we can
do simple plots if you don't know much
about matplotlib real quick to get back
to the original screen you just hit this
home button to go back to the previous
screen you can do this this back arrow
and then back to the other one forward
arrow this is so you can drag the whole
thing around and this is so you can zoom
in to a spot and then finally this is to
configure if you have a bunch of
subplots sometimes the spacing is funky
so you can just play with these this is
area from the top right bottom left this
won't change anything here so we don't
have any subplots but that's you know
space in between the two sides
it's a wit space and then h space for
head space but again we don't have
subplots but anyway if you're not
familiar quick run through both those
options so anyway we'll close out of
this and so we can see how we can plot
clothes now the other data that's pretty
similar to clothes or will you know at
least of the same scale is clothes
we have clothes ha to capitalize it hi
whoa open and then we did just to find
100 ma so we might as well show 100 ma
so we can save and run that now wait for
it oh something's mad what did we do
Oh big dummy okay it's gotta be a list
within okay so put your brackets around
one more time there we go beautiful plot
super fast no issues of loading now let
me show you guys something else that we
find nice I believe that this would be
pandas matplotlib version only if you
just saw our little legend be-bopping
around very nice code sometimes the
legend gets in the way but as you can
see with this current version the legend
just is running away from our plots as
best it can sometimes that does not work
for you if you're just plotting normally
with matplotlib so it's actually really
nice to use pandas their renditions and
their code of matplotlib now this is
probably matplotlib code i don't know
what code you can do for the legend to
make it run away like that that's just
nice because map huh I mean pandas
understands that that should be the
defaults matplotlib does not so anyway
so that's it that's with just some quick
basic plotting with pandas it is super
simple to plot with pandas and so it's
just really nice to have the simplicity
there and yeah so especially with the
dates so that's gonna conclude this
tutorial just some really quick graphing
there's a whole lot of other things that
we can do with graphs a lot of people
want to do like candlestick graphing and
all that and if you're interested in
doing really fancy stuff I do have
tutorials on all kinds of fancy stuff
for graphing you can check those out if
you want otherwise you can just use this
basic stuff that's going to include this
tutorial on 2d graphing now in the next
tutorial I'm just gonna show you real
quickly 3d graphing and I don't think
that pandas has 3d graphing built right
in because you have to import that
specifically from pandas I mean from man
plot lib but I'm gonna show you guys how
to do 3d charting just in case you want
to so stay tuned for that if you have
any questions or comments
this video please feel free to leave
those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the scores
subscriptions and until next time